so you heard even small streamers can
make money on twitch and you want to
know how to make that happen in today's
video we're gonna talk about my first
$100 on twitch and how much you can
expect to make as a small streamer and
also how soon people of the Internet
retro records who are here your guide to
family-friendly content in the world of
video games so you're sitting there and
Quarantine and you're thinking hey these
guys make money on twitch however if I
could start making money on twitch I
want to get that started what would I
need to do to make money on twitch one
thing I want to say right from the start
is it is okay if you want to make money
on twitch far too often I feel like
there's this negative stigma online
surrounding people who want to make
money at content creation at frankly
doing things they love and that just
never made a whole lot of sense to me if
you're interested in making money on
twitch go ahead and smash that like
button below raise your hand don't be
afraid don't be shy of course you need
to love doing it and not be only in it
for the money but I want to say to you
today very cool it just because you want
to make money on twitch does not make
you a sellout it does not make you a bad
person now of course there are plenty of
folks out there who pursue YouTube and
twitch just for the fun of it and if
you're one of those people that is
totally okay as well this video is
really more for people who want to
pursue this as a side gig as a source of
a secondary income or maybe even one day
as a full-time career if you found
something that you love and that you're
passionate about and there's a chance
you can make money you can make a living
off doing it and why wouldn't you go
after something like that and that leads
us straight into number one what are
your expectations the answer to this
question guys depends entirely on you
are you single do you have a family to
support do you have a job right now what
is your current financial situation look
like in almost every case out there
you're not going to be able to go all in
from the beginning now if you're in
college or you're single and you have a
stable financial situation and sure go
for it but I think most people out there
aren't going to be able to fully dive in
like that you don't have to go all-in
right from the beginning in fact I would
encourage you not to go all-in
from the beginning if you guys already
know what your expectations are for
making money on twitch do me a favor go
ahead and let me know down in the
comments what you have identified is
your expectations for how soon do you
think you can start making money on
twitch and how you plan to go about
doing that number two how much money
have I made as a small twitch streamer
so I received my first check in February
2019 and I still have the email saved it
was forward ninety nine dollars and 80
cents and the weight which works guys is
they don't pay you immediately when you
receive a sub so you have to reach $100
in your twitch account before they will
pay out to you now most of the money
made on Twitch is going to come from
tier one subscriptions which cost $4.99
or Amazon Prime subscriptions which are
free more on those later you as the
streamer will get exactly half of that
which is around two dollars and 49 cents
and for those of you who aren't as
familiar with twitch before you can make
any kind of money at all you have to
reach the rank of affiliate so April
2018 when I started June 2018 when I hit
affiliate I didn't receive my first
paycheck from any kind of subs until
February of 2019 probably thinking why
did it take so long guys this is the
journey of a small streamer now some
people have done it way faster and then
there are other people who have never
done it at all and then there are a lot
of people right in that same boat that I
am now in terms of the context here I've
been streaming regularly since that time
when I hit affiliate status now I work
full-time I'm a husband and I'm a father
to two kids so there are three huge
things on my plate right there that
impact my stream so most of the time
over the course of that roughly two
years I've streamed about three times
per week for maybe two to four hours
depending on the street I just passed
four hundred followers in April of 2020
and in total as of the end of April 2024
roughly two years of streaming I have
made around $600 now that is only
including subscribers and bit donations
that does not include any direct
monetary donations of which I received
some not a lot but I have received some
of those along the way now just hearing
those
furs definitely give you all the
information you need some of you out
there are probably saying you made $600
playing video games and then others of
you out there are probably saying $600
over two years that's it people are
making millions on Twitch context is
everything guys my expectations going
into twitch or I wanted to see if I even
enjoyed doing it I wanted to see if I
liked playing video games in front of
people I wanted to see if I was good at
it I wanted to see if I could manage all
the equipment and technology that goes
into it as well so I started streaming
playing fortnight don't do that don't
start with Fortner that being said I
knew what I was getting into I didn't
expect to blow up and get tons and tons
of followers and subs playing fort night
it was really more about getting the
experience for me so again I already had
a full time job if I made money at it
great if not hey we'll see if I enjoy it
if I want to keep doing it I also think
it's important to take into account what
sort of audience you have going into
twitch and when I say audience you might
think what exactly do you mean do you
have followers on Twitter do you have
friends on Facebook what about Instagram
if you're on any kind of social media at
all then you probably have at least a
small group of people that follow you in
some capacity going into this I had a
couple hundred followers on Twitter and
a couple hundred followers on Facebook
that was my audience and finally our
last point today is how can you make
money on Twitch as a small streamer how
do you start getting those first
subscribers number one step is you have
to reach affiliate there are numerous
resources online and tell you how to
reach affiliate status I will also
include a link down in the description
that points you directly to the twitch
website where they tell you exactly the
steps you need to take to meet affiliate
status so once you reach that affiliate
mark and you want to start making a
little bit of extra money right away
here are the two most important things
you need to know number one Amazon Prime
and number two your friends and family
guys this is by far the absolute easiest
way to start making money on Twitch is
talk to your grandmother talk to your
parents talk to your brothers and
sisters talk to your close friends
anyone you know
it has an Amazon Prime of which there
are a lot of people let them know that
you have started streaming on twitch and
that there's a way they can support you
monetarily for free there's still so
many people out there guys that have
Amazon Prime but don't know anything
about twitch and don't know that it's
basically money just sitting there from
Amazon waiting to go to many many
streamers out there so of that $600 I
talked about I guarantee you that over
85 to 90 percent of that money is from
my friends and my family so I will also
include a link down in the description
explaining how the Amazon Prime and
twitch Prime relationship works
basically if someone has Amazon Prime
they can sign up for a free twitch
account link those two accounts and then
they get a free sub each month that they
can use on any streamer they choose
including you as soon as you hit
affiliate status so let's say you can
find roughly 10 friends and family to
support you like this and that would
mean in about four months you would have
$100 ready to be paid out to you from
twitch now for anyone out there who
doesn't have Amazon Prime they can still
support you with a tier 1 or tier 2 or a
tier 3 subscription but that's when they
actually have to put down real money
which is certainly a bigger step for a
lot of people out there you can also
make money from donations and you can
also make money from bit donations and
bits are basically just twitches way of
handling donations directly also
friendly tip here twitch Prime subs do
not auto renew so those close friends
and family you're gonna need to send
them little reminders each month
just a little polite nudge saying hey
guys would you mind going and doing that
again they don't you have to watch your
stream all they have to do is go and hit
that twitch prime self each month to
help you out now there are a ton of
streamers out there and some great
youtubers in fact I'll link a couple of
them down in the description who will
help you grow your twitch stream and
teach you proven tactics once your
family and friends start supporting you
guys then it'll kind of just be like
this little snowball that starts to roll
down this hill and hopefully they'll be
able to help you build some momentum to
grow your stream make sure you offer
benefits
to subscribers as soon as you have
twitch affiliate status guys to work on
getting some custom emotes that you
create that your fans can use in the
chat also you want to make sure that you
mentioned how they sell now this one's a
little tricky because there's a careful
balance here you don't want to come
right up and beg for subs and by all
means do not guilt people for not
subbing but you definitely want people
to know once you hit that affiliate
status that they can support you with a
subscription if they choose a really
great way all around of reminding people
that they can sell is by recognizing the
people that already do so if you have
those family and friends who are
supporting you have a little scroll on
screen that shows their name make sure
you thank each and every sub that comes
your way guys if you found anything
helpful today I ask that you please
consider hitting that subscribe button
and don't forget to ring that Bell so
you won't miss any of our future videos
I want to thank you guys for watching
the video today and I'll talk to you
again soon